[Applaudissements]
une nouvel épisode il en pense quoi ton
frère il en reste est plein ils ont été
tellement adorable mais tous les
chroniqueurs se sont prêtés au jeu il
déguise pendant que voilà quelqu'un
répond à la question et ça donne ça
regardez qu'est ce que vous pensez des
transports en commun parisiens hyper
pratique ces transports en commun
parisiens ce qui permet de rejoindre un
point à un autre dans paris très
facilement et votre frère et dans penses
quoi
je n'ai pas de faire malheureusement
parce qu'on pense mr mais franchement je
suis assez fade h et un officier nadeau
des transports parisiens au sahel dont
est utilisé dans beaucoup d'autres
villes et c'est ici qu'on est con à les
transports en fait les les plus rapides
et votre frère il en pense quoi
saperlipopette dis donc globe trotter tu
as voyagé partout c'est ici qu'on se
retrouve et b ironie du sort de ma
casquette je trouve que c'est pas mal
desservies paris quand même et votre
chat l'on pense qua non mais ça va pas
du tout il y en a plus trop bas à un peu
merdique toujours en retard et votre
frère il en pense quoi
sur le trans caraquet mamans du quartier
chic de coupiac de pipe
qu'est ce que pensent et les transports
en commun par je prends le bus souvent
le métro très peu et votre frère ils en
pensent quoi encore j'adore les
transports mais j'utilise tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps j'adore ce
problème c'est que s'il y avait moins de
bagnols les bus circulerait plus
facilement et notre frère il en pense
quoi
enfin moi je veux des place en fait
retrait de tout comprendre
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens je pense qu on a
trente ans de retard par rapport au
métro d'autres capitales européennes et
vos frères il en pense quoi
moi je sais pas ce que tu en penses
frérot mais au risque de choquer un peu
chauve qui est moins en moins de belles
mais faisons métro tout à fait tout à
fait tout à fait d'accord avec toi
[Musique]
bon